do you always complain that you're
feeling bloated
and that your belly looks bigger than
what it should be
that heavy feeling in your abdomen is
often due to various causes
related to sluggish bowel and a poor gut
health
this can be due to constipation fluid
retention
indigestion allergy a poor diet
stress lack of sleep or certain
digestive disorders
it's basically an excessive buildup of
gas solid
and sometimes liquids in your digestive
system
you're not alone i've suffered through
bloating and indigestion for many years
and through the years i've learned that
what i do in the morning can have a
major impact
on how my digestive system functions
later in the day
so here are five things i practice daily
in the morning for a flatter belly
and a healthier gut don't eat
immediately upon waking up
i'm sure you have known about the
importance of eating breakfast
and some even recommend that you should
consume breakfast within
30 minutes of waking in order to ensure
they
charge up their metabolism and get fat
burning going
i do believe that there can be lots of
benefits to eating breakfast
however i don't believe we should
consume breakfast
immediately upon waking up now
remember that your metabolism is not
going to just
shut down overnight so your metabolic
rate is still going to be
running at a steady pace when you're
awake
it's not like if you don't eat breakfast
first thing in the morning
your body will stop burning calories
that is
absolutely not true at all personally
i'm not someone that can just wake up
put my clothes on
rush out of the door and grab something
to eat on the go
a rushed morning means a rushed
breakfast
and eating too fast can be seriously
detrimental to your
gut health and contribute to indigestion
and bloating
later in the day i need time in the
morning to wick
my body and brain up and also to get my
digestive system going
so i've learned that having heavy solid
food upon waking up
it's not going to do my gut health any
good and it will
leave me feeling bloated that being said
you do need to know your own body if
you're a breakfast person
then you can consume breakfast one to
two hours after waking up
and make sure you find at least 10 to 15
minutes to sit down
and consume your meal mindfully drink
at least two glasses of water on an
empty stomach
the first thing you should be consuming
in the morning on an empty stomach
is water why is it so important
your body has been without water for six
to eight hours when you're asleep
drinking two to three glasses of water
right when you wake up
is a must to rehydrate your body quickly
in fact
rehydration after an all-night fast can
fire up your metabolism
improve digestion reduce bloating and
curb
your appetite as a result cutting down
on your calorie intake
it sounds like a really simple thing to
do however
most of us do forget or don't make the
effort
so i like to have a huge bottle of water
next to me
before i go to bed once i'm awake i'll
make sure to rehydrate myself
first thing in the morning drinking
water in the morning can also help
flush out all the toxins that's stored
in your body overnight
it naturally stimulates movements in my
bowel and ate my morning spree to the
bathroom
so if you're someone who do suffer from
constipation regularly
drink water on an empty stomach first
thing in the morning
take prebiotic and probiotic supplements
i'm sure you have heard me say this many
times our
gut is our second brain a healthy gut is
key to a healthy body
if you're constantly bloated experience
digestive issues or
constantly feeling lethargic and moody
that's a sign that your gut is not
functioning at its optimum
this is where taking prebiotic and
probiotic supplements can
really help they're both equally
important
and play different roles probiotics are
food or supplements
that contain life microorganisms meant
to maintain or improve
the good bacteria in our body on the
other hand
prebiotics are a type of fiber that the
human body cannot digest
and they serve as food for probiotics
we need both prebiotics and probiotics
to keep
our immune system strong and to support
our overall digestive health
i've been consuming our's causal health
drink every morning
this is a 100 natural supplement made in
japan
and it has gone through a one year
fermentation using traditional japanese
methods
hence this drink provides a balanced
nutrition
combining prebiotics probiotics as well
as
postbiotics which is the byproduct of
the good bacteria to gain the maximum
benefit i'll consume
one serving of ours corso mixed with
half a cup of water
every morning on an empty stomach either
as my breakfast
or at least 30 minutes before my first
meal
and what i really love about this is
that it's made
from over 100 different vegetables
fruits and plant-based ingredients
including seaweeds and mushrooms
so imagine all that goodness in this
one serving every morning to boost my
gut health plus
this is really delicious this super
drink is available in the u.s with free
shipping
plus international shipping is also
available
you can use my discount code joana10 to
get 10
off your purchase personally i've seen
positive changes
i don't experience indigestion or
bloating anymore
and my body is able to better digest and
absorb nutrients from the food i consume
i've also seen improvement on my energy
level as well as fitness performance
and also improvement on my skin and hair
health i think once your gut is able to
function at its optimum
you'll see and feel tremendous
improvements on your overall health and
well-being
and it all starts right here
next is to do a mini morning workout
i'm not asking you to do an hour long of
intense heat workout or strength
training just 10 to 15 minutes of
movement a day in the morning can make a
huge
difference to your digestion in fact
i'll keep it
low impact and low intensity activities
such as yoga
breast walking or a total body
functional training
can help to stimulate your digestion and
speed up your
bowel transit for me my mini morning
workout session will be walking my two
big
babies for about 20 to 30 minutes around
my neighborhood when we walk or move in
the morning
we're activating our body system and
this gives you energy for the rest of
your day
i believe that it's something that we
all should practice even as we get older
because it's going to support our health
and well-being long term
and finally my favorite drink green tea
i filmed several videos just on the
benefits of green tea
a warm cup of green tea is
anti-inflammatory
and has a high concentration of
antioxidants called catechins
drinking green tea in the morning and
even throughout the day
improves metabolism aids digestion and
eliminates
the buildup of gas in the intestines
which brings down
bloating in your tummy green tea also
helps to reduce fluid retention
and eliminate excess water hence you
won't
feel so puffy on top of that regular
consumption of green tea has been found
to reduce body fat especially around the
abdominal area
that's why i love green tea so much
so try swapping your morning cup of joe
with
green tea and remember you want to be
consuming the unsweetened
green tea not the green tea latte loaded
with added sugar
okay with all these morning tips and
tricks
remember that your gut health still
comes down to your lifestyle
eat a well-balanced diet and avoid food
that causes
inflammation get enough rest daily move
daily do things that will reduce your
stress levels
and boost your mood learning what causes
bloating in your daily life can help you
get on the right track
if your bloating is persistent you may
want to speak to a doctor
but many times these symptoms can be
dealt with by changing
your everyday habits if you enjoy this
video if you find this video to be
useful
then do give this video a thumbs up like
this video
share this video on with your friends
don't forget to apply
these tips into your morning routine and
hit the subscribe button okay do check
out my channel for a lot more
workout videos nutritional tips healthy
recipes
as well as meal plans and i will see you
next time
all the best